hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the semi-final match of
the chess.com Global Chess Championship
final series nihal sarin versus Anish
giri and uh We've covered their fifth
game yesterday the first four games were
uh were very nice but the fifth one were
on each one with that brilliancy was
just a masterpiece and we said that uh
well it's uh now now it's up to nihal to
bounce back and uh well did he bounce
back or what this is game six of their
match uh played uh Niko having the white
pieces and it's just a spectacular game
so let's dive straight into it and see
uh how and why it happened so nikal has
the white pieces and he opens with D4 we
have Knight to F6 uh C4 yeah Anish goes
for Pawn to E6 and Bishop to F4 this is
a very very rare continuation in fact it
is the seventh most popular continuation
uh in this position we have Pawn to D5
by any c captures Knight captures and as
the bishop is attacked the bishop back
to G3 Pawn to C5 attacking White Center
here and pawn to e for challenging the
Knight we have Knight to F6 and now
Knight to D2 just regarding the D4 uh
sorry uh Knight Knight D2 not Knight to
E2 sort of giving up the D4 pawn and uh
it seems like you shouldn't be able to
do it but uh you know if you want you
can capture it and it's not a new move I
mean the position has been reached
before uh in fact this year uh in the
USGS Championship Hans Neiman had it
against Ray robs and Ray Robson
continued with Knight to C6 and he won
the game with the black piece but here
Anish just as a c captures and D4 show
me uh why why this is bad for me and
okay Ponte E5 anyhow grabs more space in
the center chases away the knight from
F6 Knight to D5 and Knight G2 F3 we have
Knights the C6 and now Pawn to A3 taking
care of that B4 square and now comes
Knight Dita E7 there is a game where
Bishop t7 was played but here we have
Knight D2 E7 and it is now as of move 10
that we have a completely new game nihal
goes Bishop to D3 and now you see that
um
uh with the the pawn being an E5 it's uh
it's a bit of an issue for black you
can't put a knight on F6 and you kinda
want the castle King side and with the
light core Bishop controlling this
Diagon you know that the White Queen is
coming to E2 then the E4 it's gonna be
it's not gonna be all that easy to
defend your king side so the pawn
sacrifice is definitely Justified and
and it just goes Knight to F7 uh he puts
pressure on the dark Square version also
he closes up this diagonal so Bishop to
F4 nehal says uh I'm not even allowing
you Knight captures on on G3 and he
hints at the idea of advancing the pawn
to G4 so Bishop t7 by Anish we have Pawn
to G4 and now Knights the H4 we have
captures an H4 Bishop captures and now
Knight to F3 this is how the Knight is
reintroduced into the game at the bishop
is now under attack Bishop back to E7
and now Queen to E2 and it's uh it's a
big problem for a niche how to continue
the game and now just give you an
example if you Castle you can play this
black does not lose by force but it's
very hard to play it for example Queen
E4 now you threaten Checkmate and after
G6 Bishop to H6 you attack the rook and
now black would have to find this very
nice F5 move
where if you uh okay if you capture e
captures an F6 Alpha sound then Rook
capture so your Rook is no longer Under
Fire if G captures then also Rook
captures on F5 and if you play something
like Queen to F4 then you would have to
go into this F characters and G4 idea
open up an attack towards the queen you
have to give up the rook and f8 and then
Queen to A5 check forcing King to F1 and
not even G captures on F3 and while you
can play this for example Bishop
captures Knight captures and H4 with H5
coming uh it's not uh it's not all that
great you will be able to defend and
it's okay to play this but it's a rapid
game so I mean it doesn't look like you
should be able to play this like only if
you were an engine you would play this
so instead we have Pawn to A5 and this
uh is also uh very nice because Anish
wants to push the pawn all the way to A4
and if nihal castles Queen side which
you probably will then you can shift the
Knight into the attack maybe Knight A5
Knight to B3 also the root can be
shifted into the attack uh and that's
how you will get counter play as now you
you know that it's going to be a race so
here we have Ponte H4 and now Pawn to H5
we have G captures on H5 Rook captures
an H5 and now Rook to G1 putting
pressure on G7 and Anisha uh has to
choose whether he will defend with
Bishop to f8 or King the f8 he decides
to go King to f8 and here nickel just
castles Queen side and now it's
definitely a race
and Anish should continue with his plan
of Ponte for and then bringing the Rook
into the attack uh and so on but he goes
for Queen to D5 which is a very deep
idea only it's uh not really working in
this position okay the immediate threat
of Queen to A2 is very easily Perry with
King to B1 and now comes the anisha's
plan look at this Rook to F5 yeah he
offers the exchange here but if uh
nickel goes for this bishop captures the
pawn captures then he frees up the E6
Square for his bishop and it's not gonna
be easy to play this uh to give you an
example it's in ig5 Bishop captures and
G5 Bishop captures and queen to e for
check uh already uh puts a lot of
pressure on white you don't even have to
go for this bishop T6 ID and now you
have to trade queens and black has this
beautiful Central Pawn structure
controlling a lot of squares here and
yes you are down the exchange but with
these pawns you will be fine but instead
we have Bishop to e for uh um not being
greedy for The Rook we have Queen to B3
and now comes Knight to D2 attacking the
black queen and here Anish plays Pawn to
D3 because if you just move the queen
back and then give white Time Queen to
G4 is coming and you are not going to be
able to defend this so so here Pawn to
D3 and it's a very tricky move because
there is only one move that wins the
game for nihal and you guys of course
will be uh tested to see if you if you
can solve this so feel free to pause the
video and to win the game for nihal
while I give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding your
way throughout this entire mess because
you really have to calculate a lot and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is best Shop characters and
D3 now just for fun I will show you what
happens if you go for Queen to G4 here
okay you probably already noticed that
Queen to C2 check can be played but look
at this a Queen City Check King A1 now
comes the best shop captures on A3 and
not what do you play Checkmate is being
threatened by black now you have to play
Queen captures on G7 check King E8 Queen
to G8 check King to D7 and now uh what
do you play if you capture the bishop
which seems like it's your only option
but then night before and black wins
there's no defense Queen A2 will be
Checkmate and if you capture the Knight
then just a nice discovered Checkmate
from The Rook so the bishop cannot be
captured after King to D7 you would have
to play Knight the C4 attack the bishop
defend the B2 pawn and now after the
Knight is captured you will play Bishop
captures on F 5 and after Bishop
captures on B2 check King characters and
queen to see to check there will be
nothing better for white than to go for
a nice Perpetual after Queen day one
because the black king is also under a
lot of pressure with the D3 Pawn hanging
so you would have to settle for a nice
draw here King B2 Queen B4 checks
something like this so that's what would
happen if you just go for the attack
with Queen to G4 after Bishop captures
on D3 you eliminate any and all counter
play now Queen to C2 check is no longer
an option and now uh well there's just
no good way to continue probably best
for a niche would be to give up the
queen here for the rook and Bishop on F4
something like captures captures and
will captures an F4 but still it's uh
um not going to be possible it's it's
basically a rook and a dark Square
Bishop for a queen it's not all that all
that great and maybe if your pieces were
nicely developed but not like this so
instead after Bishop captures on D3 we
have knighted the D4 by Anish going
after the White Queen Queen to E3 not
putting pressure on the Knight and queen
to A4 defending the Knight we have
Knight the C4
now blocking the Queen's defense of the
Knight and D4 and now just Knight the C2
and he finds a way at the same material
but it doesn't really help him all that
much so Bishop captures on C2 attacks
the queen queen recaptures the peace
with Queen captures and C4 and now the
cleanest and quickest way to win this is
Bishop to H6 beautifully played by nihal
uh maybe I even put this for the
position on the thumbnail as it just
leaves black without a move so you can
easily resign here no one would blame
you point is that if the bishop is
captured Queen captures an H6 King the
E8 now comes Rook the G8 check and after
Bishop to f8 just Queen captures an f8
Checkmate The Rook of course he covers
the entire D file so after Bishop H6
Anish started running with King the E8
but now nihal just played The Rook
captures on G7 and he was in this
position on move 29 that Anish giri
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here uh now Rook to Jade
is coming the the f8 square is covered
by the best of that will be Checkmate or
you know very quickly will get
checkmated and if you try something like
F6 to give your king a little bit of
breeding room here just Bishop captures
on F5 and now the bishop cannot be
captured uh because just e characters
and F6 and you uh will not be able to
withstand all of this pressure on the E
file and if you don't capture the bishop
it doesn't really help you all that much
or you can play something like Bishop
the D7 maybe try to hide the king this
way but then Bishop G6 checking to d8
and you get checkmated this way Queen B6
check King to C8 and now Rook the G8
check and there are no defenses here all
of the squares here are covered by white
pieces uh so whatever you block with
will just get captured in the end once
you give up any uh you know as a
material that has to be given you will
finish with Bishop to d8 and then Rook
or queen capture 78 will be checkmate uh
so yeah afterward captures on G7 uh
Nikon not only bounces back but he
bounces back with a vengeance after a
niche won that brilliant scene in round
five if you haven't seen it it's my
previous video do check it out and he's
truly played a brilliant brilliant game
with the white pieces and then something
very interesting happened the game
um seven and game eight ended in a draw
and they had to play an Armageddon game
and in Armageddon uh nihal was
Victorious and he is the one who
advances to the finals of the chess.com
Global Chess Championship Finals where
he will meet uh the winner of the match
Hikaru versus Wesley so if you haven't
seen it I will spoil it now so you know
don't listen uh it will be Wesley so
versus nihal sarin it was a quite a
battle between Hikaru and Wesley but
Wesley was able to I think they started
with six draws and then Wesley won the
uh two final games with the Hikaru
blundering a rook in time traveling
gaming for something like that it was uh
it was a true spectacle if you've seen
it live but yeah it's gonna be a very
nice match in nihal versus Wesley we're
gonna see what happens uh I'm sure it's
going to be one one great match uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it once again a big
congratulations to everyone who found
that idea it's it's very tempting to go
for Queen to G4 right away but if you
realize you have to eliminate the pawn
that already it makes you a very very
mature player
so yeah once again really hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank Martin
your paparik um
subramanian Aaron is the best fiance and
Marcus grebel uh for a global for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions uh and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day